بيان المشترك ام اعلان ام لا شيء بماذا
ستختتم قمه مجموعه العشرين مجموعه من قسمه
من اجل وبسبب روسيا والحرب في اوكرانيا
رسميا الحرب ليست على جدول الاعمال فعليا
هي الحاضر الاكبر في كل النقاشات العالميه
وفي الكواليس اللقاءات الجماعيه او
الثنائيه الاساسيه او الهمشيه في بالي
تبدل تعاطي القاده الغربيين مع الصين وعم
الود حتى لو كان ظاهريا مؤقتا اغلب
اللقاءات التي جمعت الرئيس
الغربيين وعلى راسهم
ان في ذلك كل متحدث معه طلبا ملحن الضغط
على روسيا لانها الحرب في اوكرانيا في
مدخلته اثناء الجلسه الاولى اكثر من رد
دعا الرئيس الصيني دول العالم الى التصدي
بحزم لمحاولات التسييسي واستخدام الغذاء
والطاقه سلاحا وجدد معارضته لسياسه
العقوبات الغربيه قال ايضا ان المواجهه
بين التكتلات والترسيم الايديولوجي سيؤدي
الى تقويه التقدم العلمي من بعيد خطب
الرئيس الاوكراني الحضور في بالي وبينهم
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
في القمه
على جميع حدود دولتنا مع روسيا شروط تركيا
اصدار بيان ختامي يدين موسكو
الغربيون تسييسا البيان الختامي واضافه
عبارات من شانها ادانه تصرفات روسيا نيابه
عن جميع دول مجموعه ال 20 فلنكن صادقين
ودعونا نعلن ان لدينا اراء مختلفه فيما
يتعلق بهذا الموضوع نعم هناك حرب هجينه في
اوكرانيا ودائها الغرب وكان يعد لها منذ
سنوات
او اعلان فرصه تبنيه طائله جدا وبدون
روسيا مستحيله تتحدث الوثيقه عن التداعيات
السلبيه للحرب في اوكرانيا وبان معظم
اعضاء المجموعه 20 يدينون بشده النساء كما
يعتبرون استخدام السلاح النووي او التهديد
به غير مقبول مع الدعوتي الى تنفيذ
اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب
موسكو اقرب الى قرار عدم التمديد بعد
تاريخ التاسع عشر من الشهر الجاري شمل
المجتمعين في قمه بالي تفرقه الحسابات
والمواقف من حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا